well let's talk about actual censorship
yeah let's talk about this
is one of the uh we saved it for last in
the event that uh uh
we're gonna get banned or something yeah
because uh listen
as here's here's the context donald
trump
tweeted out a story uh it was a video um
about these doctors it was a press
conference where they were talking about
hydroxychloroquine i'll be very careful
about
how we we phrase this because you know
we record these segments live
and if you say something out of line
they're watching the live streams they
will hit the x button and delete this
stream
midstream just gone outright but we got
to talk about the censorship
yeah this is one of the most egregious
censorship scandals
in the history of this nation i'm not
exaggerating by this this may be a
historical moment
the president of the united states sent
out a video a press conference from
literal doctors you can argue they're
not good doctors but they were actual
doctors
and they were giving you they were
giving advice as they saw it
perhaps they were wrong that's fine but
if the president wants to send a message
over a digital platform
why shouldn't the president be able to
do that yep all of the big companies
removed this video
here's the important point breitbart
which filmed the live stream it got
about 18 million views before it was
deleted across the board
this was a news organization whether you
like them or not they are
protected under the first amendment
filming a press conference
and they got all their videos nuked of
actual doctors
of actual doctors now some of these
doctors have said apparently or at least
one of them has said things that are
quite
silly about you know banging demons or
something
that's the point at the point if the
president wants to put something out who
is twitter
facebook or youtube to argue they are
they have more authority than he does to
address the nation
let's go back in time could you imagine
if there was a president
in say like the 80s and they decided to
do an uh
they decided to do a you know to address
the nation
and all the big networks went the
president is going to address the nation
on some very serious crisis and pandemic
nah cut him off and then also the
channel just turned him off
sure they could choose not to amplify
his message
but that to me would be ridiculous now
they've started doing this
when during during the height of the
pandemic trump was giving daily
briefings and then all these networks
started
like cutting them off and and no longer
airing these because they were like he's
lying
no it was because they were being made
look bad because his approval rating
everyone was watching him and then they
were watching the news and going
what you guys are crazy that's not what
he said his approval rating was
skyrocketing
to the highest it had ever been in
aggregate and then all of a sudden they
were like cut him off cut him off it's
helping him stop stop yeah
and so that to me is is is quite frankly
insane now to be fair
trump was doing daily press briefings at
a certain point you're like
maybe we don't just keep showing this
every day but here's the crazy thing
the ratings were up for these companies
their ratings were improving
by showing this this is what the people
wanted to see they wanted to see the
president addressing the crisis
and they liked it when he did so they
stopped it because it was helping him
well now the president and the
president's son
are being negatively impacted donald
trump jr received a 12-hour suspension
for tweeting out the video where he said
something like wow
this video sure you know challenges the
narrative or something
yeah no he he said people are upset
because this goes against the narrative
why not just remove the video like
anybody else good point
why did they suspend his account well
he's he's way more open against going
against the narrative
then right the president is so how
insane is it
why why does twitter facebook and
youtube have a medical
advice policy why do tech companies
have a medical advice policy how is it
that i can say over and over again
take advice from your doctor don't
listen to the president or the pundits
your doctor knows best for you
enter the doctor and then when these
doctors speak up yeah
they delete all the videos yeah that to
me is
well it's interesting too because at the
beginning of the
the press conference they straight up
say we are sick of of politicians
pushing forward this you know this
narrative
what they're not doctors well we're
doctors and we're here
because we feel americans need to hear
from actual doctors that's like
the first thing out of their mouth is is
that in that press conference
they said look into the research by dr
harvey
risch of yale so i did
guess what i found what this story from
newsweek
harvey a rich md phd
professor of epidemiology yale school of
public health adam do you know what a
professor of epidemiology
studies it sounds like viruses and stuff
yeah infectious diseases epidemics
epidemics hey epidemiology huh and he
says the key to defeating covenant 19
already exists we need to start using it
whoa whoa whoa oh it's oh you said
opinion afterwards so we're in the clear
it's an opinion well i think the
important thing is
what they're arguing is that these
doctors in this video
used a specific word i'm not going to
say just in case right
i know what you're talking about yeah
they like basically arguing that
it was the end-all-be-all treatment
we'll put it that way
if that matters i don't know maybe we'll
still get axed from from youtube
yeah but uh here's what here's what he
writes as a professor of epidemiology at
yale school of public health
i have authored over 300 peer-reviewed
publications
and currently holds senior positions on
the editorial boards
of several leading journals i am usually
accustomed to advocating for positions
within the mainstream of medicine
so have been flummoxed to find that in
the midst of a crisis i am fighting for
a treatment
that the data fully support but which
for reasons having nothing to do with a
correct understanding of the science
has been pushed to the sidelines as a
result tens of thousands of patients
with covet 19 are dying unnecessarily
fortunately the situation can be
reversed easily and quickly
i am referring of course to the
medication hydroxychloroquine when this
inexpensive oral medication is given
very early in the course of an illness
before the virus has had time to
multiply beyond control it is shown to
be highly effective
especially when given in combination
with the antibiotics azithromycin
or and the nutritional supplement zinc
let me tell you all right now i know
full well
saying these things could be a strike on
this channel
it could be the banning of our content
there's a line for me
i've often talked about how there are
certain things i'll you know
avoid because it's irrelevant yeah
saying certain words or whatever or
certain people's names
or a certain name a cio whistleblower's
name i can't say because you can still
find the information so long as i can
prompt you to look for it
this is a red line a yale md phd
writing saying here's what i believe is
quite literally
the expert ivy league phd
doctor of epidemiology says it i don't
know what expert is left
you can't go any higher than that yeah
you can't you can't
so when he says this i say i respect his
opinion yeah
in the end i still recommend you talk to
your doctors who know what's right for
you because
you know one of the things i don't know
if you guys are you ever ever have
soylent
yeah so soylent was like this goal at
making this
meal replacement that was like could
totally replace your meals the problem
was
everybody's body is a different size
shape and there's not a
like complete set of nutrients you need
so it ultimately doesn't work that's the
point
your doctor knows your like your health
and what will work best for you
this opinion is interesting so why is it
that a video shared by the president
showing similar opinions from several
doctors is bandworthy
yep i'll tell you what i did a video on
this early in the morning
uh earlier this morning on my other
channel tim cass news it's still up
got a ton of views like 300 something a
thousand and
i say the same thing you know what if i
get banned for saying this so be it i'm
reading newsweek.com
yeah if i can't read newsweek and i'll
tell you what that caa guy's name
i've had videos deleted because of it
for they they they do this thing it's
really strange
where they either force private the
video so that it's still in your library
but it can't be made public you don't
get a strike
they just say nope the video is
invisible now or
they remove the video without even
telling you one of my videos got removed
they never even said anything to me
until one day i got an email from i
started getting emails from people
saying
yo that video you did on that guy is
gone
and i was like what i went into my
youtube and sure enough there it was
like an image nothing to click on it was
still there in my youtube backend
but the metrics metrics were gone and it
was just an image that i couldn't click
and it was the weirdest thing that made
no sense
they refused to reinstate it absolutely
freeze there was another video
where project veritas exposed and
employed a tech company who was engaging
in censorship
they did the same thing but this is the
line for me
if we can't talk about this and share
this information yeah then
it's it's over it's over it's i don't
know what else you do right
you can't this this cannot be ignored
yeah i mean well look at uh
phillip anderson for example he he is
really outspoken
you know you can follow him on on
instagram uh kingfreespeech
and he talks about he goes out every
night he's fighting against antifa
fighting this courthouse and he's open
about talking about
what we need to do we need to you know
protest twitter banning people he's been
banned twice from twitter why
why because he's talking about the
narrative that they're
pushing that that's what that's what
this is that's why
this donald trump jr got uh what was it
it wasn't banned he was
they they said we didn't suspend him we
were restricted we restricted some
features for 12 hours
right and the some features was the
ability to tweet
yeah yeah the only thing that you're
there for
you can read i guess but whatever
this is the big secret about censorship
on social media
well first of all the the secret to
everybody knows
is that the big tech ceos are lying they
do
censor based on ideology yeah the
evidence has been revealed over and over
and over again we have screenshots we
have
we have witnesses on the record what
happened to journalism
i'll tell you what project veritas
apparently is the only place you're
going to go to where you're actually
going to see the evidence and the
witnesses where they acknowledge it
everyone else says well but veritas lies
yeah it's a picture what do you mean
they're lying they photoshop that no
but here's the big secret they mostly
target smaller accounts
they want to stop accounts from rising
they want to
they want there's a cutoff point and
i've talked about this on youtube
where they change the rules and they
don't like the idea
that the internet created a meritocracy
of notoriety
where random and regular people could
become very prominent and famous just
through hard work
they need to be the gatekeepers so what
they've been doing
is when someone like this philip
anderson guy starts getting followers
and speaking they say no no no cut him
off cut him off we do
not want another you know uh terence
williams on our hands
we can't have another candace owens we
gotta stop him yeah so they ban him
and it prevents him from going now i'm
being a bit more
you know hyperbolic or exaggerating they
just target smaller channels who can't
fight back
that's true and that's that seems like
and that's the that's the bulk of a lot
of the censorship
well i'm gonna keep talking about him so
what did you see this no what is this
zuckerberg to paint facebook as proudly
american company
contrast with internet mark zuckerberg
model
mark zuckerberg banned paul joseph
watson from instagram
and paul joseph watson's instagram was a
bunch of selfies of him on like on the
sunset smoking cigarettes
and it was it was it was like the
silliest thing i'd ever seen
i remember that it's just like a guy
like he's like he's like there's a
sunset behind him and he's like got a
cigarette in his mouth and he's like
what up
and they were like nope nope far right
banned
they're just purging pro-trump
personalities because
whether you like their politics or not
that's ridiculous you're gonna ban
someone from instagram when they only
post you know selfies
or actually another really good example
is the banning of the donald on reddit
yeah exactly which which was uh like the
most prominent forum
they moved over to the donald.when i
mentioned this quite a bit but this is
serious because
four months for four months the the
reddit site
their subreddit was inactive they had
already relocated
and they prohibited people from posting
and then four months later they
announced
they keep breaking the rules so we're
banning them and it was like wait a
minute
nobody was posting are you retroactively
enforcing rules
without giving them a chance to fix it
or are you lying
you know what you know what i think i
think they were already gonna ban the
donald and they were gonna wait until
just before the election
but the donald moderators preempted
reddit
i think because everybody knew was going
to happen the goal was wait to the 11th
hour
to stop them so they can't reorganize
right so because they jumped off four
months in advance
they were able to get a lot of their
core audience from reddit onto a new
platform
the donald dot win then when
they when their plan kicked in over
reddit to ban the donald
which made no sense because no one was
even using it
all of a sudden it didn't matter they
already had a fast-growing forum on a
on their own private site that couldn't
be banned anymore this is the big trick
the big secret we need we need to enact
we need to enact
decentralized social media but i agree
100 on that i think back to the days
when we all used to have our own
websites
and urls and stuff you know there was a
period where
people would actually just buy a domain
make a website and then it was like you
know
gifs of macho man and you know like
mario
and it was like really silly star colors
yeah just really and maybe music playing
the background
midi midi files and then we started
getting these
centralized social media where it was so
easy to create a profile
which functioned as your website that
people just said i'll just do this
instead
we need to go back to this and i don't i
don't necessarily know
who or how or when or why but i know
there's several solutions in play like
the feta verse
one of the ideas that needs to be
implemented which kind of is already
being implemented and
implemented by people would be like this
a system like twitter
and as a base called the f what's called
the fetiverse
you create your own server on your own
website no one can ban you
and people can subscribe follow you just
like twitter
and when they go to their uh you know
site they can see everyone they
subscribed to
and no one has the authority to ban
anyone i like that that's where we need
to get to
yes how now how we do it i don't know
it's really hard to get people to move
over to other platforms
i see a lot of people jumping over to
parlor which is cool
but parlor is still just another
centralized social media platform
where you are going to get banned if
their business interests are threatened
sorry that's just the way it is if the
merchant accounts for parlor went to
them
in my opinion and told them you have to
ban these people otherwise we're
severing
payment processing for you what are they
gonna do are they gonna say i guess
we'll let the whole site
you know be deleted or we'll ban this
one person
i'm willing to bet they're gonna ban the
person and say i'm really sorry but if
we don't we get purged from our payment
processor
that's why we need decentralized social
media we need it now
yeah agreed yep so what is this
zuckerberg
zuckerberg to paint facebook is proudly
american company
contrast with chinese internet model
yeah this is bs he's not gonna do that
no he's gonna try to do it well i mean
we
well what we talked about the other day
about how they're trying to
bring him to court again for lying a
couple years ago about
not being biased and then of course
project veritas exposed that to bs
so now now he's trying to be like no
we're an american company we're
look he zuckerberg along with cheap
executives of amazon
apple and google are set to testify
before a house judiciary commit
subcommittee on
antitrust wednesday as part of a group's
invest investigation into competition in
the digital
marketplace i love it it's going to be
fun
he's going to be like oh we we at um
facebook actually deeply proud
of this country and we love this country
um just i'm a billionaire because of
this country just not the people that
like the president of this country and
jack dorsey is going to be alike
when we actually think that twitter is
beholden to a global audience so we are
actually going to defy
u.s law and make rules for
the international community see but
we're slower we exist but slower
we exist outside of the law so i've
actually never heard him speak i don't i
i just like that i'm actually doing an
imitation of sheamus doing an imitation
of jack dorsey he's good
from from freedom too james is good at
impressions i'm like i haven't i haven't
listened to jack speaks since
i was doing the podcast like over a year
ago but his ben shapiro was on point
yeah yeah yeah i think uh
at this point i think jack's lying
yeah i gave him the benefit of the doubt
i've i've i've talked with jack on and
off since
jack dorsey of twitter since we did the
uh the podcast with joe
and he keeps saying all these things and
it's kind of just like
it feels kind of like an abusive
relationship where
you know the guy keeps beating the woman
but keeps promising to do better and she
keeps going back to him and he keeps
beating her and that's social media
because people are addicted they can't
give it up now
uh jeremy hambly with the quartering i
guess he deleted his twitter account
good for him yeah he's he's got it he i
don't know how many followers he had he
had a decent amount
he's got yeah he i don't know if he had
like 100k or whatever i'm not super sure
he deleted his whole account and he was
like follow me on parlor instead and i
was like
you know what man i almost i almost
deleted my entire twitter
maybe like a year ago and i stopped and
i thought to myself you know what
instead what i'll do is i'm gonna stop
interacting with people on twitter
okay that's it i'm gonna stop tweeting
at people and i very
rarely ever tweeted people and i always
make sure that if i do tweet
it is like i try to do my best to
mitigate against any perceived
hostilities
okay so typically when i respond to
somebody in any capacity it's extremely
rare
and it might be something and further
into the conversation i specifically
avoid
when i see a tweet from someone and
they're lying and it's nasty it's
obvious
i just go right past it i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna get involved i'm not gonna
tweet
them yeah i'm starting to take that on
too just if someone comes
you know with clout and it's just like
i could waste my energy and try to
explain
to this person but they're not gonna get
it
they're they don't care it's pointless
why am i gonna waste my energy when i
have all these other people that are
like
i got you back you know let's let's
further the conversation
you know and that that's great i like
that and i've been adopting that myself
you know just
just you know what if you got nothing
nice to say if you don't want to further
the conversation
have a legitimate conversation because
there's a difference between having a
conversation if you don't agree with me
and just coming at me with some some bs
you know what man yeah
i look at some of these political
personalities on social media
and you know what the lowest tier of
political personality is in the world
what reply guy and the lowest tier of
that is trump reply guy yep they build a
following by tweeting at donald trump
lol and like you're so dumb yeah reply
guys
definitely bore me just like get your
own thing
say you got to have ideas yeah yeah
share your thoughts on something people
people
you know crazy i've had people ask me
like you've got so many followers on
twitter now tim like how do you do it
and i'm like
i don't know when i don't care i don't
pay attention yeah i kind of just tweet
the things i feel
yup exactly uh and that's it i i will
quote people sometimes i quote tweet
people sometimes
i will tweet things i'll tweet videos
and you know
one thing i can't i kind of don't like
about twitter is that people assume like
a journalist will tweet a story
okay and then people will assume it's
the journalist's opinion when they tweet
a story
oh yeah and they'll attack the
journalist and i'm like come on just
because the journalist tweeted out
doesn't mean they're they're supporting
it
you can't assume that the same way you
can't assume i am when i tweeted out
well
and i've been doing that a lot i've been
passing along actual facts
you know like it's no opinion i i'm not
i don't have any i didn't even say what
this is a simple fact that here is this
this this is a fact
and then people are like oh wow are you
surprised at that how are you so
surprised that that's the case and it's
like
when did i say that i yeah this is a
fact i tweeted it it's interesting
and i'm passing it along to you there
was a photo that andy noah posted of the
vandalism and the destruction and the
garbage in the morning in portland
and he was like here's the destruction
they leave behind yeah and he said the
rioters
and then i quote tweeted and i put an
asterisk peaceful protesters tm
as a joke like andy andy they're not
rioters they're peaceful protesters
don't you remember
and someone's response was so you're
saying that it's justified for the feds
to use unmarked vehicles to kidnap
people and i was like
what i didn't say anything so i
responded with no i'm saying
i'm making fun of the media for calling
them peaceful protests is when they're
clearly violent
yeah like that's it and so i'll respond
to people sometimes and they respond to
me
rarely though because i usually don't
even check i typically don't
but twitter is the joke is that
you'll tweet something like i really
like waffles and then people will be
like why do you hate pancakes ah and
they're all attacking you
yup twitter and cakes waffles are better
than pancakes
dare you but you know twitter knows this
and they do it on purpose they know that
waffles are better than pancakes twitter
knows that they've created a rage engine
which is tearing the country apart
yeah they know for a fact that they do
well it didn't start with twitter it
started with media
well no internet no twitter gamified the
process of
hate where you earn points the more
hateful you are you don't think
that started with facebook before
twitter became a thing no
yeah i don't think so so facebook is
is relatively different there is always
argument and discussion on facebook but
you create these isolated
comments beneath a post okay with
twitter
you can dunk on someone and then someone
can grab that and show it to all of
their friends too
whereas on facebook if i post a picture
of like a dog doing a backflip and then
you comment tim you're dumb
no one's going to click share on your
comment to have your comment just appear
on their page to everybody else get it
yeah i see it's just twitter different
style so uh
what facebook does and it does cr
facebook created a different system for
creating rage it incentivized publishers
to make people hate
twitter incentivizes regular people to
earn points likes shares retweets and
followers
by being as nasty and disgusting as
possible
just to be evil and mean and you the
funniest part is
i i i try to avoid it right and so often
say to people like
you know i'll respond to a progressive
with with like a fair point that i think
i'll calmly and be like here's why i
think this is happening
and i'll get inundated by their
followers with insults slurs
name calling i ignore most of them oh
yeah but then when the people themselves
put me on blast like the progressives
i'll respond with like
i don't understand the hostility i'm
just trying to you know have a
conversation
and then they do it again they'll screen
grab it take it out of context and try
and gain followers based off of the
attack on the other
i see that a lot actually that's the
whole system no i'm talking about you
specifically because absolutely
people are like yo did you see this this
person talking about tim poole
on you know and i'm just like oh i'll
check it out for a laugh
and i look and it's just someone look at
what tim poole tweeted
look at this look what he said and then
look at the people that are following
what they're saying i'm like
this is news this is what you're
reporting on this is
this is what people want to see i don't
know no they don't they don't care about
this person and that's why no one knows
there's a quote i don't know the full
quote maybe you got you could look it up
or something it's like
small people talk about other people oh
yeah i think that was eleanor roosevelt
let me see
was it yeah pull that quote up because
that quote's pretty good but it's
basically like
yes they talk about other people so
bigger people talk about ideas
right things ideas and people i think it
is
yeah it's like yeah i think it's like
what is it like small people talk about
people right than like bigger meet
bigger people talk about things seeming
to find the actual quote ideas or
something right
yeah i know you're talking bigger people
talk about ideas yeah yeah so i talk
about people sometimes but i usually
keep it to the highest level of
authority and power
yeah and it's interesting because one of
the arguments i got from a smaller
youtuber as to why they constantly make
videos about me
is that they're punching up at me yeah
and i'm like what do what do i do other
than
like be a guy in a studio talking about
his feelings and reading the news
i don't know exactly who he was but it
was a it was kind of like a ted talk but
it was in india
and it was this this man sitting and
talking to a huge group of people and he
was talking about how
celebrity status and putting people
putting people up on a pedestal
and put you know looking down at people
because you think you're up on a
pedestal
and and the the key is to treat everyone
as
the world on the same level yeah you
know and and all these people are
are attacking you like you just said
punching up at you
but they're putting you up on that
pedestal above them so therefore
it's them putting them up there putting
you up there and being like oh he's up
there
there are people that are so right so
desperate to get me involved
in drama yeah i'm sure it's the most
annoying thing when i get emails
you know the most annoying thing is when
people i know message me on facebook
saying things like dude did you see what
they said about you
and i'm like if you send me that
anything like that ever again i will
unfriend you i will block you
yeah like do not send me stupid gossip i
literally do not care
i don't care what people say about me i
don't care what they think it's a waste
of my time
boom waste of time waste of my time yeah
you're wasting your time you you
i got so much on yourself focus on what
you need to do
and stop being angry that someone else
is focusing on what they're doing
it's getting angry at them for that that
people that blows me away that people
are seriously just so angry
at other people when that that's all
they do they're people that they're
being angry at other people
it shows you what they think how how
much they care about how much
what they they care about how much they
care about what other people think about
them
yep yeah and i'm like i i don't man why
do you care so much
what other people think about you i'll
just post stuff and you know mind my own
business
we talked about it though it's that lack
of confidence you know they they
are seeking approval because they don't
they
aren't fully accepting of themselves and
didn't get approval growing up maybe
that i mean that's one one option
you know but it's that lack of
confidence that they themselves aren't
confident enough so anything
you know that upsets them or anything
throws them off it's someone else's
fault also
you know so thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast we do
the show
live monday through friday at 8pm if you
want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you